many economists breathed a sigh of
relief after march's consumer price
index was released yes the report showed
the annual u.s inflation rate was the
highest since 1981 but
it also suggested inflation may have
peaked and will begin to slow down since
then however markets have shown
investors expect higher inflation for
longer i'll explain why longer-term
inflation expectations have picked up
what we're seeing in the market that
shows this and what that means for the
broader economy let's get into it i
think we're at peak inflation
and because of that we're a peak fear
investors don't think inflation's going
to keep rising but they also don't think
it's going to come down very quickly
that's due to some new uncertainties in
the world and some old ones being
exacerbated the first is the war in
ukraine which has continued longer than
most expected and currently has no end
in sight that's keeping pressure on oil
and wheat prices which are major inputs
to a slew of other food and household
products there is also the recent covett
outbreak in china that has led to
lockdowns and further disrupted supply
chains and housing prices are still
rising at a double-digit pace in the u.s
outstripping economists expectations
when investors expect high inflation
bond yields rise and prices fall so we
can see this in markets recently we've
seen yields on longer dated government
bonds like 10 20 and 30 year maturities
reaching multi-year highs the 10-year
break-even rate which measures investors
inflation expectations over a decade
touched a record high in april rising
above 3 percent for the first time since
tracking began in 2003. i asked rick
reeder managing director at blackrock
about the market moves he said that
inflation has gotten stickier meaning it
will be harder to get rid of he agrees
that inflation is probably peaking but
warns it's not like you're rapidly going
down the other side of a mountain it's
more like you've climbed the mountain
and now it's going to be a gentle
descent down from these levels of
inflation stickier inflation means
prices continue to rise which will add
more pressure to family budgets it'll
also put things like home ownership out
of reach for more people but a slower
yet still elevated pace of inflation
could mean that wages start to keep pace
with overall price increases so average
americans could start to see real pay
increases for the first time in quite a
while higher inflation also creates an
environment where there are more assets
to invest in that offer some income with
less risk that's especially good for
retirees and those on a fixed budget but
any positive outcome for the economy
hinges on the federal reserve being able
to rein in inflation to be sure runaway
inflation has never happened in the u.s
and few think it's likely now but
runaway inflation erodes the value of a
country's currency hobbles the economy
and makes even basic household goods
difficult to afford that's why central
banks prefer to inflict a little pain by
raising interest rates to slow down the
economy then let inflation get out of
control the fed has made clear recently
that they think there's a lot more work
to be done they're expected to raise u.s
interest rates at twice the normal pace
at their next meeting and the fed fund
futures market shows investors believe
they'll raise rates double time at
multiple meetings this year subhadra
rajapa head of u.s rate strategy at
cecilte general tells me that inflation
expectations are also rising because the
market is starting to question the fed's
ability to be effective at this point
the inflation battle has economic
organizations like the world bank imf
and oecd all lowering their expectations
for global growth and increasing their
expectations for inflation so buckle up
because this could be a bumpy ride
andre 3000 of the legendary outcast had
some wise advice for times like this he
said promise me you go stack promise me
you gonna ball promise me you'll invest
three-fourths of it all
that's all for now see you next time